Whether you're trying to lose 20 pounds (9 kilos), get promoted at work or quit smoking
Being committed to your goal is not easy. After all, 45% of people give up
New Year's Goals One Month Later. So, why is it difficult to maintain motivation?
And how can science help us achieve what we seek?
In a study conducted by the Massachusetts Institute of Technology, students were given two kinds of tasks. In the first task they had
Press the two keys of the keyboard as much as possible in 4 minutes, and do it faster
Will get the money. For some, the prize was $ 300 and others were only $ 30.
What is interesting is that performance was 95% higher in the top prize group ($ 300), showing how money can be a catalyst.
But in the second task, the same students were asked to solve a more complex mathematical problem
This time, the students who received the highest award were performing slower than students with the lowest prize of 32%
This is known as "distraction theory" when we are asked to perform a task
Requires the solution of problems or economic pressure or emotional, this causes the shift of focus from the target to the catalyst
Which quickly distracts you and reduces your performance as well
When we take a look inside the brain, MRI shows that people are completing
Challenge just what fun is and the people who complete it for an award show the same activity in the brain
But what is interesting is that if we ask who offered them the prize the first time participate
Again without an award, the rays indicate a lack of activity in the frontal and frontal lobe regions
And are regions of the brain responsible for self-stimulation. It seems that awards can eliminate the normal sense of our fun.
So, how does this apply to you? Well, it seems that "fun" is the strongest catalyst
For change in sustainable behaviors. It makes sense to complete the fun activities
But given that 67% of sports club members do not use, it seems that most of us choose the wrong activities
To reach our goals. You can burn a lot of fat on a treadmill,
But not if you stop using it after just two weeks. Choose something you really like to do.
Your goal itself also matters, in a study to find the reasons for training revealed that those who focus
Weight loss training for 32% of those who said they were training to feel better
In their daily lives
While it is always good to be positive, optimism can not always be
The best way. In a study of 210 women trying to quit smoking, the participants just imagined
Great success with few consequences were less likely to reduce cigarette consumption.
Positive thinking can often fool the brain into thinking that you have already achieved the goal
Giving you a sense of victory and reducing your motivation. But that does not mean negative thoughts are good
Imagine the goal being achieved, then think about the obstacles that stand in your way
Is the best way to think. Which is known as "mental contradiction"
Finally, try to avoid the effect of "hell" this behavior was first known
When scientists gave some dieters different sizes of milk-flavored syrup - ranging from small to large -
Then they gave them ice cream afterwards. It seems that those who got the large size of milk flavored also did
Eat a larger amount of ice cream because "the hell I've already ruined my diet I can do what I want now"
Doing so will lead to more problems on the road to success
Whether the goal is to have fitness, quit smoking or work progress. It will make you soon
From turning your goal into reality
Want some motivational tips for short-term goals? Such a duty that must be delivered tomorrow?
Watch the latest video "AsapTHOUGHT" on the best tips to overcome that feeling of laziness
Please click on the link "Display contact details"
Special thanks to "Audible" for supporting this episode and providing a free trial for 30 days
On Audible.com/asap This week we wanted to nominate "No Sweat" by Michelle Seger,
It brings you years of research into sports training and motivation in simple ideas aimed at
To your support to overcome the failure of the training. You can get a free 30-day trial at Audible.com/asap
To choose from a wide range! We love them because they are great on the road
Subscribe to our channel for more weekly videos!